hey guys I just got out of doing a
little segment in Kitchener were just
like two hours away from my home in
Toronto and we're just taking a little
little coffee break Starbucks break and
I thought I would address I some some
controversy around sponsorship because
there's definitely been a lot of
misconceptions around sponsorship and
like conspiracy theories about
dieticians being shills for industry and
things like that and you know I love to
be super transparent with you guys about
everything and so I thought I would give
you a little bit of behind-the-scenes
insight into how exactly sponsorship
works for dietitian content creators
like myself so first of all let's talk
about how things work over Abby's
kitchen as a general rule of thumb I
keep my sponsored content to no more
than 25% of my total content calendar
across all my platform is YouTube you
know my blog my Instagram etc TV
magazines whatever and so all of my
content both my sponsored and unspun
sered I make decisions about what I want
to post based on a few really simple
pieces of criteria one what am I really
excited about and passionate about right
now and two what is it that my audience
is asking for now if you go over to my
blog Abbie's kitchen you'll see I cover
a lot of different things more much
wider range I would say then then I
cover on my channel here because I have
such a more diverse audience I think on
my blog I have a lot of different
interests and also my audience are very
inquisitive and they have a lot of
interests as well yeah like the mom
recipes and the baby recipes may not
apply to you if you're like past that
mom's age or you're not a mom or you're
not a parent you're not feeding little
ones but you know the vegan recipes
might not apply to that busy mom who's
just like struggling to feed her picky
toddler who only wants to eat grilled
cheese so here at Abby's kitchen I
really try to be inclusive and
ultimately create really valuable
content for everyone and anyone who
loves to eat and who loves food now the
way it usually works is that I will
reach out to a brand that I really
admire and kind of talk about working on
a specific piece of content with them or
a brand wants to work with me
because we have similar philosophies and
those are aligned and therefore they
will reach out either directly to me or
to my agent talk about that
collaboration in the case of the latter
when a brain is reaching out to me
there's almost always a very specific
product campaign or piece of content
that they're looking at collaborating on
so it's really up to me to determine
whether or not that product is something
that my my philosophy and and my
expertise is well aligned with now if I
don't already know this brand really
well which is rare because I love to eat
and I love trying new products and I get
new things all the time to check out but
in the case if I don't I'm not really
familiar with the product the first step
is I need to try any to evaluate it and
trust me there are a lot of brands that
I say no shoot no matter how much money
they offer simply because it does not
past this initial kind of sniff test
that the taste test or the nutritional
test one that really stands out to me as
an example is Splenda you know I don't
use Splenda and I don't think it has a
whole lot of nutritive value and so even
though they've reached out to me on a
number of occasions for a number of
campaigns I've declined because it just
doesn't work for my you know my it
doesn't fit in within my philosophies
it's not well aligned with my brand so I
don't feel comfortable promoting it I
also want to flag that and acknowledge
that you know healthy for one person is
is not going to be healthy for another
because I have such a diverse audience
watching my content and I really try to
be inclusive of that and ultimately
healthy is not like a black and white
concept and as a dietitian my goal is to
really help to try to meet people where
they are so yes of course like a
convenience product may not be as
quote-unquote healthy as cooking that
that food from scratch however if it
helps a family have a relatively
balanced meal together as a family I
think that's a huge step in the right
direction and definitely something worth
promoting so like I said it's really
about meeting people where they are in
their journey towards better health so
next I want to talk about the actual
content itself of course brands will
have some things that they want me to
get across however I am super vocal
about exactly how I want to incorporate
a brand to my content and
exactly you know how I want to talk
about it all of my content is 100%
evidence-based and well aligned with my
personal and professional opinions it is
not fed to me by a brand hard stop
so no dieticians are not just puppets
for industry in fact I would never say
that a certain food is essential for
health and I would never claim that you
know you need to follow one type of diet
in order to be healthy I really try to
be inclusive and I think that the brands
that I work with really reflect that so
one week I might be working with a
yogurt brand and then the next week of
course I might be working with a you
know vegan pho meat company I have no
agenda here as long as it meets that
that basic criteria of you know my
nutritional and taste tests I also want
to flag that you know despite a lot of
like conspiracy theories and things like
that that are floating around the
messaging that I get from brands is
never extreme it's not it's usually
something like yogurt is rich in calcium
and probiotics or something like that
it's totally benign and in fact based
ultimately in fact a lot of the brands
and commodity boards that I work with
they have very strict marketing
guidelines that they need to abide by so
for example when I work with the almond
Board I'm not even allowed to say
something like almonds are healthy so
you can see like they're really really
strict and almonds obviously are rich in
healthy fats and things like that so it
makes sense that that is something that
would come out of my mouth
however those kinds of statements are
not allowed and that brings me to
another really important point and that
is what sponsorship is not so when I
partner with a brand for a sponsored
content it is for a very specific
campaign with very specific messages and
a very specific product it's not forever
more it doesn't not work like that I
mean finally I want to talk a little
about disclosure here folks now I am a
stickler for disclosure so anytime I
work with a brand that relationship is
always disclosed so the FTC which is the
Federal Trade Commission which aims to
protect the public from you know false
advertising and market
campaigns and things like that have
stated that any influencer working with
a brand needs to disclose the
relationship verbally in a YouTube video
at the beginning and at the end of the
video they needs to be in the
description at the top of the video so
that people can see it without having to
scroll it needs to be you know you'd say
sponsored or ad in any social media post
you need to tag the brand and use the
branded content tool I do all of these
things and I do them religiously so if
you're watching a YouTube video and a
person just starts talking about a brand
like you know halfway through the video
and they haven't disclosed in the first
30 seconds of the video and there's no
disclosure that the video is sponsored
in the video description itself that
person is breaking the rules and
honestly they can get in a lot of
trouble for that not to mention it's
just totally dishonest when it comes to
your relationship with your viewers and
your in your and your fans so this is a
person that you should ultimately be
distrustful of so next I want to talk
about my my content and also my brand
because any of the content that I put
out there needs to be grounded in
evidence and also in my own personal and
professional philosophy just because I
support a plant-based diet does not mean
that I can't also support a diet that
contains animal products meat and dairy
because guess what both can be healthy
and balanced or both can be unhealthy
and unbalanced as a lot of my what I in
today reviews have shown that isn't
contradictory that is me being inclusive
and ultimately that is my brand so I
would never say hey one week chicken is
essential for building muscle and then
the next week tell you that chicken is
bad you've never heard me call it a food
as being bad and then the next week
promote it because I was being paid to
that just it's never happened and it
won't ever happen so ultimately I never
contradict myself with sponsored and
unspun serd content because ultimately
my brand is very clear all foods can fit
I support people with a wide range of
dietary patterns and and I'm saying all
the time you know you do you plant-based
carnivore something in between a
combination whatever works for you works
for me personally I know like I
have a bit of like a flexitarian diet if
you want to label it but I've been very
open and hopefully as an bias as
possible talking about the benefits of
plant-based a plant-based diet and I've
talked about that here I've talked about
that and like legit every single video
I've also been very open and honest
about the fact that I am NOT vegan so my
brand isn't vegan my brand is an even
flexitarian my brand is a evidence-based
dietitian who wholeheartedly believes
that all foods can fit what feels good
to one person won't feel good to another
person and that is totally okay
diversity is beautiful it really is even
with diets if you go on my blog you'll
also notice there's a ton of unspun serd
vegan recipes and the reason for that is
because they satisfy those two pieces of
criteria that I talked about earlier
this is something that I'm interested in
because I'm excited about eating more
plant-based and this is something that a
lot of my audience is interested in as
well that's it and if you don't like
vegan recipes that's why I also create a
lot of non vegan recipes things like the
casseroles and the sheet pan meals and
the things that are great for for
families because that is another popular
request and also something that I'm into
as well here's the bottom line a
responsible influencer does a few really
important things one responds to her
audience and their requests and let me
tell you I get a diverse set of requests
too it really stays true to her own or
his own brand both with sponsored and on
sponsored content and three is
transparent honest and in my case as a
dietitian evidence-based that is my goal
here at Abby's kitchen and I will
continue to fight to uphold it so if you
guys have a very specific question that
you want me to focus on leave me a
comment below as you know as I've talked
about right here this channel is not
just about me it's really about you guys
and what you want to hear and see so
leave me comments questions this is all
what informs all of my content don't
forget to like this video subscribe
share it and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]